[Musica]
che cosa è impossibile
voi pensate che sia possibile girare
completamente il mondo su una vecchia
vespa come questa
attraversare i cinque continenti 26
paesi per oltre 40mila chilometri da
solo senza sponsor senza mezzi di
appoggio senza navigatore gps o telefono
satellitare senza abbigliamento
specifico manco una carta di credito e
neppure il parabrezza
pensate che sia possibile io non ero
affatto sicuro temevo che fosse
impossibile come del resto in tanti mi
dicevano prima di partire però ho deciso
di provarci e ci sono anche riuscito
sono partito da genova e ho continuato a
viaggiare verso est senza mai invertire
la rotta fino a fare ritorno al punto di
partenza però provenendo dalla direzione
opposta
non è stato affatto semplice se pensate
che abbia fatto una vacanza siete fuori
strada è stata durissima per riuscirci
abbiamo dovuto affrontare e superare un
sacco di ostacoli attraversa la regione
difficilissime prima delle quali spesso
la popolazione locale ma avvisava
preoccupate mi diceva guarda che con
questo cesso di moto non ce la puoi fare
ad arrivare lì torna indietro e
impossibile è impossibile sempre la
stessa storia
io è il ds che è un modello della mia
vespa del 76 però ce la facevamo sempre
lì smentivano sempre e così dopo un po
abbiamo cominciato a chiederci ma che
cos'è l'impossibile
noi abbiamo attraversato desertiche sono
luoghi terribili dove il clima le
distanze possono uccidere da quelli di
sabbia soffice come in iran inizierà nel
nord del brasile dove le ruote
sprofondano e si piantano a quello rosso
ruggine dell'outback australiano fino al
terribile atacama in cile
dove non piove da 73 abbiamo risalito
strade di pietra scavate nello scoglio
vivo sul fianco delle montagne più alte
del mondo in nepal per giungere ai piedi
dell'himalaya rimanerne sbalordite
abbiamo percorso per settimane sterrati
desolati a 3500 metri sull'altopiano
andino e abbiamo scavalcato la dorsale
principale a 4.750 metri dove attorno e
solo ghiaccio roccia 0 vegetazione
abbiamo visto il titicaca il lago
navigabile più alto del mondo un luogo
magico mistico culla di civiltà
antichissime uno dei posti che più ci
hanno fatto vibrare abbiamo attraversato
fiumi mastodontici come non credevo
potessero esistere fiumi larghi anche
più di 10 km quei nomi esotici come il
gange brahmaputra in india l'ira wadi
mia mar il mekong lo abbiamo costeggiato
per centinaia di chilometri perché in
indocina dove scorre segna il confine
naturale tra laos e cambogia mentre
sulle acque del rio delle amazzoni
abbiamo navigato per oltre duemila
chilometri nel cuore della foresta a
bordo di una barca di legno
il ds tra bancali di banana e cipolle io
tra le amache degli altri 100 passeggeri
straiato sulla mia ad ammazzare zanzare
a 35 gradi all'ombra come il colonnello
aureliano buendìa e soprattutto ad
aspettare il mio turno per l'unico certo
a bordo
e tuttavia circondati da una bellezza
che non so descrivere ho guidato il ts
fino a pochi metri da luoghi incredibili
hanno guidato fino ai piedi del taj
mahal in india o la borsa khalifa a
dubai sono gli edifici più bello e più
alto del mondo e ho guidato sulle strade
di pietra dell'ancor fat la
straordinaria capitale degli antichi
khmer in cambogia un popolo che sta
all'indocina come gli antichi romani
ma l'europa
scusate l'ho portato letteralmente a
sbattere contro le pareti di roccia di
loro che è questo enorme monolite rosso
piantato nel centro dell'australia sacro
da millennio gli aborigeni che
strutturalmente come un iceberg quello
che vediamo non è una minima parte lui
si conficca chilometri sotto la crosta
terrestre lo guidato dentro la piazza
più bella del mondo durbar square e
kathmandu dove risiede la mari la dea
bambina evidente e lo guidato nella
indescrivibile di scheda di stupa
millenaria di bagarre antica capitale
birmana
l'ho portato fino ai piedi del machu
picchu che in lingua quella significa
montagna giovane quella punta dove sorge
la favolosa città perduta di pietra
degli antichi inc che si trova
nell'attuale perugia ha guidato il ts
nel traffico immane di metropoli enormi
da quello ordinatissimo di dubai e
singapore a quello folle caotico di
santiago del cile o istanbul quello
pericolosissimo di tirana e la pace fino
a quello per cui non conosco aggettivi
efficaci nella nostra amata lingua delle
metropoli ma anche dei villaggi indiani
dove non solo non esiste un codice della
strada ma neppure sembra di essere il
buon senso
io la prima volta che ho imboccato
l'autostrada a mumbai in direzione nord
verso il gujiarat e alla terra di gandhi
ho trovato i camion che mi venivano
addosso in entrambi i sensi di marcia e
ci ho messo un giorno intero a capire
che lì a causa delle terrificanti
condizioni dell'asfalto
il traffico si ritiene libero di
percorrere la carreggiata nel senso di
marcia e desiderato dove pensa che ci
siano un po meno buche
ho cambiato quattro pistoni due cilindri
due frizioni in acre nella mazzoni a
brasiliana a terra del grandissimo chico
mendez forava almeno due volte al giorno
per una settimana intera
ho percorso 1.500 chilometri
completamente senza freni tra thailandia
malesia ho saldato i portapacchi decine
di volte e ho guidato spesso di notte
ko un buio così fitto che mi toccava a
fermarne aspettare che arrivasse una
macchina e lanciarmi l'inseguimento per
usare i suoi di fare
ho visto il mondo almeno una grave una
grossa parte e ho pensato è osservato
tanto perché la scena di una vespa è un
luogo assolutamente privilegiata da
quello che ho visto e che più mi sta a
cuore raccontare
ho provato di creare una raccolta di
punti e avrebbe dovuto essere un
decalogo ma me ne sono venuti solo 8
quindi a rigore si tratterebbe di un
etologo ma essendo un termine
terribilmente cacofonico preferito
chiamarlo un decalogo zoppo punto primo
già street e lo ricordate lo slogan
pubblicitario di una marca
semisconosciuta di scarpe di qualche
anno fa già scritta un'espressione che è
difficile rendere bene in italiano ci
sono almeno un paio di traduzioni
possibili quella che preferisco io è
fallo e basta il mio già street era di
girare il mondo su una vecchia vespa e
l'ho fatto
non importa che ci sia riuscito quello
che è davvero importante che io ci abbia
provato il successo è un premio non
necessario
se anche il vostro già street e di fare
un viaggio vedere il mondo
fatelo non abbiate paura ma non serve
affatto un viaggio lungo e difficile
come il mio
il viaggio è una medicina straordinaria
e potentissima o curare qualunque
malattia ho bisogno dello spirito ma la
posologia e assolutamente soggettiva
basta un viaggio molto più piccolo del
mio per trarne benefici ma se il vostro
già scritte non è un viaggio ma è
tutt'altro che è cambiare lavoro
scrivere un libro lanciare col
paracadute è la stessa cosa
just with fatto le basca punto 2
non sempre quello che viene dopo e
progresso questo l'ha scritto manzoni
quasi 200 anni fa nel romanzo più noioso
della storia della letteratura mondiale
è un concetto straordinariamente vero
attuale però il progresso che intendeva
manzone non è lo stesso che siamo
abituati a pensare noi intendeva
progresso nell'accezione etimologica del
termine il termine progresso dice
wikipedia designa il processo di
avanzamento e sviluppo delle discipline
delle culture tramite mutamenti nel
corso del tempo che hanno come scopo il
miglioramento delle condizioni umane
quelli di manzoni erano tempi in cui
suffragio universale o l'abolizione
della schiavitù erano ancora ben lontani
da venire da questo significato che lui
dava alla parola progresso
noi da almeno un paio di decenni ci
siamo abituati a confondere a fare
coincidere il significato stesso della
parola progresso con quello che non è
una che non è che una sua semplice
declinazione ovvero il progresso
tecnologico
ormai quando si parla di progresso
istintivamente pensiamo subito
all'ultimo modello di smartphone o e
megapixel della sua fotocamera
io di mestiere faccio il tecnico ho
grande rispetto per la tecnologia ma
credo che il vero progresso non sia
andare sulla luna o per quanto ne guarda
a fingere di andarci progresso umano è
la componente umana non quella
tecnologica
a determinare il vero progresso è il
grado di cultura consapevolezza e
compassione che ogni civiltà in grado di
raggiungere punto tre il pianeta è
malato noi ne siamo veleno e antidoto
questa è una banalità lo so e me ne
scuso però nel mio viaggio io ho potuto
osservare da vicino agli effetti
evidentissimi per esempio del
surriscaldamento del pianeta o dell'uso
folle che come umanità abbiamo finora
fatto della plastica e ne sono rimasto
sbalordito in sud america ho visto un
deserto neonato che avanza dalla costa
del pacifico su verso la cordigliera
delle ande il deserto è come attila dove
arriva lui non cresce più nulla
in india ho visto dei fiumi
completamente ricoperti di plastica
buste bottiglie soprattutto quali non si
vede più l'acqua scorrere sotto
io credo che noi non dobbiamo più
permettere che la lotta all'inquinamento
venga considerata come una opzione come
una possibile strategia che venga
valutata in termini di rapporto costi
benefici
la lotta all'inquinamento è
imprescindibile è l'urgenza la priorità
numero uno punto 4
informiamoci smettiamo di farsi
informare dalla mia generazione davanti
non abbiamo più alibi abbiamo internet
uno strumento pazzesco
ribaltiamo la dinamica classica del
processo cerchiamo di essere il soggetto
non l'oggetto dell'informazione
noi oggi possiamo lasciare che le
notizie vengano a noi o decide di
andarci da cercare prima di internet
questa possibilità di fatto non c'era
cerchiamo di confrontare le diverse
versioni proposte per una stessa notizia
e valutare l'attendibilità delle fonti
questo è fondamentale per non farsi
prendere in giro il ministro della
propaganda nazista era solito dire che
una menzogna ripetuta sufficientemente a
lungo e con sufficienti mezzi diventa
verità
questo era certamente vero ai suoi tempi
ma non nel 2016
goldberg dobbiamo mandarlo a fare nel
culo non ci dobbiamo fare fregare da
quelli che ancora oggi la pensano come
lui
perché noi oggi abbiamo i mezzi e gli
strumenti per sgamare le menzogne o
almeno per provare a farlo punto 5
la politica è solo uno strumento del
potere economico
le ideologie partiti i governi non hanno
affatto quel potere decisionale che noi
normalmente gli attribuiamo quello
conoscete enrico mattei è stato un uomo
con le palle fumanti e il cervello che
non stava dentro a questa stanza
se non ne conoscete la storia leggetela
perché merita tutta la vostra attenzione
una volta un giornalista gli chiede
quali fossero i rapporti tra lini la
neonata azienda chimica che aveva appena
fondato di cui forse avete sentito
parlare e partiti politici e lui rispose
gli usi i partiti come un taxi
ciò bisogna andare da qualche parte li
chiamo salgo a bordo vi faccio portare a
destinazione
pago la corsa e scendo questo schema è
tuttora verissimo si ripropone ovunque
al variare di latitudine culture forme
di governo se impariamo a riconoscere la
dinamica la becchiamo ovunque punto 6
lo scontro di cultura non esiste è una
balla una enorme esagerazione mediatica
è una specie di leggenda metropolitana
che non dovrebbe avere più dignità del
vero di quella dei coccodrilli giganti
nelle foglie di new york gli attentati
terroristici le ideologie assassine
esistono certamente purtroppo sono
tragicamente veri ma riguardano una
percentuale irrisoria della popolazione
mondiale e soprattutto non ne
rispecchiano affatto le volontà non è
questo che vuole l'uomo di strada io ho
viaggiato via terra sulla terra ad
altezza terra rasoterra
ho incontrato migliaia di persone in
strada gente comune gente normale
diversissima per cultura religione
valore io da nessuno ha avuto il minimo
sentore di sentimenti ostili solo aiuto
e spesso a livelli imbarazzanti e questo
è in assoluto la cosa che più mi piace
raccontare del mio viaggio perché spesso
quando lo racconta la gente mi dice che
io sono stato coraggioso che ha avuto le
palle per farlo ed è falso non servono
io non mi considero un uomo
particolarmente coraggioso anzi io
prendo per buona la lezione di charles
bukowski che diceva uomo coraggioso e
privo di immaginazione il codardo sa
prevedere il futuro punto 7 o si pensa o
si crede questo è il titolo di un libro
di schopenhauer stravede letto buon per
voi
viceversa non preoccupati della cosa
migliore del libro è senz'altro il
titolo che però è straordinario e
dirompente o si pensa o si crede è una
scelta di campo
sono due scelte antitetiche l'uno
esclude l'altro
chi decide di pensare non riesce più a
credere e chi crede purtroppo spesso
smette di pensare e mi raccomando noi
scegliamo di pensare guardiamo come
nemici ogni dogma ogni estremismo ogni
fondamentalismo il nostro cervello
nostro pensiero sono gli unici compagni
che mai
cercheranno di fregarci voi non credete
a nessuno dubitate di tutti soprattutto
non credete a questo guitto ingessato
con una vespa gialla fianco che vi ha
parlato oggi io non sono venuto per
proporre verità merce di cui
assolutamente non dispongo io sarei
soddisfatto di questo mio misero
intervento se fossi riuscito a suscitare
curiosità in qualcuno di voi tra i pochi
almeno che hanno avuto la cortesia di
non addormentarsi fino a questo punto
cerchiamo di essere curiosi
perché la curiosità è prerogativa di
intelligenza e l'intelligenza assieme
all'amore per la bellezza e
all'ostinazione sono le migliori armi
che abbiamo
ottavo e ultimo punto il lavoro paga
sempre e con questo non intendo affatto
il lavoro di otto ore al giorno per cui
riceviamo uno stipendio tendo lavoro in
accezione estensiva io credo che lavora
chi si tiene in forma che legge un libro
chi viaggia certamente lavora chi cucina
tre ore la domenica mattina per
prepararsi e tagliatelle o la pasta al
forno perché gli piace lavora chi si
informa lavora chi sogna ma lavora anche
chi perde mezz'ora per fare una briscola
con l'on
magari lo strappa alla morsa
agghiacciante del divano della
televisione questo tipo di lavoro paga
sempre e può portarci ai risultati che
noi stessi crediamo impossibile e
concludo
tornando al prologo che cos'è
l'impossibile impossibile un concetto
relativo è un impossibile è una cosa è
considerata una cosa fino a quando
qualcuno che magari fino a poco prima
consideriamo
un passo un deficiente non ci prova e ci
riesce da quel momento in avanti quella
cosa smette di essere impossibile
sapeste quante volte che il ts ce lo
siamo sentiti ripetere nel nostro anno
di viaggio e che gusto che abbiamo avuto
nello smentirli tutti l'uno dopo l'altro
io vi auguro di cuore di poter provare
lo stesso gusto nostro grazie a tutti